Evet hepinize Merhaba size bugün
küllerinden doğan yeğeni şeyin
hikâyesinden evrenin hikâyesinden biraz
bahsedeceğim o hikayenin Aslında
insanoğlunun örnek alması gereken bir
hikaye olduğunu size Anlatmaya
çalışacağım Bu sayede karşımıza çıkacak
aşılmaz mış gibi görünen tüm o
sorunların aslında önemli sorunlar
olmadığını daha iyi bir şekilde anlamış
olacağımızı düşünüyorum unutmayın
arkadaşlar herkes Dile vurur Ancak o an
geldiğinde Kafasını kaldırıp hala
gökyüzüne bakabilen insan sayısı çok
azdır Belki de bilim dünyasının yanıt
Bulmamış en büyük sorunlarından biri
büyük patlamadan önce ne oldu Dur dur
13.8 milyar yıl önce gerçekleşen ve
bugün Gördüğümüz her şeyin oluşmasını
sağlayan o ani genişleme olayından önce
acaba Evren nasıl bir yerdir yani
zamanın sıfır olduğu o Anna
işte Bu sorunun yanıtı henüz bilmiyoruz
ancak büyük patlamadan bugüne kadar
uzanan o milyarlarca yıllık süreçte ne
olduğu hakkında çok iyi fikirlerimiz var
evrenin tam sıfır zamanında değil de ona
çok yakın bir zaman aralığında saniyenin
katrilyon çarpı katrilyon çarpı milyonda
birinde bir şeyler çekmişti Evren Işık
hızından daha hızlı bir şekilde O anki
boyutunun pilyon kes katrilyon katı
genişletip anında zamanın minicik bir
kesrinde algılarımızın çok ötesinde olan
bir olaydan bahsediyor eğer o an
olmasaydı belki Evren şu an gördüğünüz
gibi homojen dağılmış bir yapıya sahip
olmayacaktı belki canlılığın oluşumuna
kadar geçen süreç farklı işleyecek ve
belki canlılık bile olmayacaktı Yani bir
sorunu çözmek için adım atmak
istediğinizde bazen O minicik adamın şey
aramayacağım düşünebilirsiniz ancak
minicik adımlar sayesinde şimdiki haline
gelmiş olan bir Evren içerisinde
yaşadığınızı epub
bu ve adımınızı atın tereddüt etmeyin
erteleme Evrenin İlk üç dakikasında şu
an Gördüğümüz her şeyin oluşmasını
sağlayacak ilk elementler hidrojen
helyum ve minik bir miktar lityum
oluşmuştur Herşey ama herşey varlığını
Evrenin İlk üç dakika sındaki o fiziksel
koşulları boştur Beynimiz Aslında 13.8
milyar yaşındayız Yani evrenle yaşatırız
bir Tekin vücudumuzda bulunan sayıca en
bol element hidrojen 13.8 milyar
yaşındadır Bu açıdan baktığımızda Yıldız
tozu değil de bizzat evrenin kürleri yiz
evrenin bir parçasıyız o da bizim bir
parçamız Evren henüz 400.000 yaşındayken
bir ışık saçtı buna kozmik arka
formasını diyoruz evrenin 13.8 milyar
yıllık hayatının ilk anları ilk kozmik
Çığlık evrende görebileceğiniz en eski
Işık bu Ben doğduktan sadece 10 saat
sonra benim fotoğrafıma bakmanız gibi
bir şey
var yani kozmik polis durumuna bakarken
Aslında evrenin bebeklik Alina bakıyoruz
son hesaplamalar bize gösteriyor ki
Evren yaklaşık 9 milyar yaşındayken yani
bundan yaklaşık 45 milyar yıl önce adına
Samanyolu dediğimiz bu galaksinin
kollarının dış kısımlarında bir yerde Şu
an tam da bulunduğumuz yerde Güneşin ve
bizim hayat Hikayemiz başlamak üzere
Kimbilir kaç nesil öncesine ait doza
dönüşüp uzaya saçılmış yıldızların
küllerinden bizim yıldızımız güneşimiz
de oldu evrendeki Herşey Muğla Bizler de
dahil iz bir gün kiloluk hikayesini son
verecek Ancak o kül olmuş bedeniniz
Belki başka bir yıldızın malzemesine
karışıp parlamaya devam edecek Kim bilir
bizim yıldızımızın malzemesi geçmişin
hangi uygarlıklarına ait Külleri
barındırıyor birleştirilen şey
Sonsuzluğa uzanan bu yolculuğumuz
boyunca sizinle olmayabilir ancak
katılımlarınız ya da atomaltı
parçacıkları nız bu yolculuğu yapacak ve
Bu bir şekilde yine parlayacak yani kül
olmanın bile bir anlamının bir amacının
olduğunu bir evrenin parçasıyız insan
olarak belki doğada ilk gözümüze çarpan
şey her şeyin Öldür Ya da fizik dilinde
konuşursak Herşey formüle iştir her ne
kadar evrenin sadece yüzde beşini direkt
olarak görebiliyor ve ölçebiliyor
olsakta göremediğimiz o kocaman kısımda
birlikte her şeyin öleceğini yani ile
Filipin'de konuşursak soğuk ile sıcak
arasındaki savaşı nihayetinde soğuğun
kazanacağını biliyoruz bir gün Evlen tek
bir yıldızın bile parlamadı buz gibi ve
sessiz bir yer hale gelecek ancak öyle
görünüyor ki şu an bir parçası olduğumuz
Evren buna benzer bir ölüm sessizliğinde
nadana büyük patlama dediğimiz bir
olayda doğdu Daha doğrusu küllerinden
doğdu ve Kim bilir bu kaçıncı olmuş Evet
evrende sürekli artmakta olan entropi
bir süre sonra Doyum olacaktır Yani
artık sıcaklık değişiminin olmadığı
Bu bir başka deyişle hareketin olmadığı
bir evrenle doğru gidiyoruz Ancak o an
geldiğinde sadece minik bir parçacık
bile o durağına başka aldırırsa tekrar
bir evrenin doğması Bir yıldızın ve Bir
canlının vücut bulması içten bile
değildir o halde en aşılmaz engeller
inen derin book anların yaşandığı
anlarda bile minik bir kıvılcım herşeyi
değiştirebilir her şeyin daha iyi doğru
gitmesi için gereken hareketi
sağlayabilir evrenin doğası bu evrende
gördüğümüz düzen evrenin çalışma
prensibi bu bu gezegenin bir parçası
olarak nasıl ki Evren küllerinden
doğmuşsa bizde engellerle
karşılaştığımızda daha güçlü bir şekilde
yolumuza devam etmeyi bilmeliyiz buraya
kadar anlattıklarım size bir şey
göstermek için de istisnasız Hepimiz
gördüğümüz göremediğimiz her şeye
birlikte küllerinden defalarca doğmuş bu
evrenin bir parçasıyız evrendeki acaba
deliğe rağmen varoluşa pençelerini geçir
bu akşam varken Hangimiz aşılamayacak
bir engelimiz olduğunu söyleyebilirsiniz
bunu hakkımız var Biz a taşıdığınız
yaşam bugünlere ulaşana dek olmadık
badireler atlattı ve öyle görünüyor ki
üç buçuk 4 milyar yıldır bu gezegende
hüküm süren yaşam gezegen ölçeklerinde
felaketlere maruz kalsa da asla tam
olarak yok olmadı mı Eğer evrende inatçı
bir şey arıyorsanız en inatçı şey
yaşamın ta kendisidir bir kez ortaya
çıktı mı onu yok etmek neredeyse
imkânsızdır yaşamın kendisi kadar
bizlerle yapmış olmayız Bizlerde
sorunlar olumsuzluklar kötü sürprizler
karşısında bu derecenin açılmalı ve
umudumuzu kaybetmeyiz Umut bizim için
yaşam anlamına gelmektedir Ben doktor
Üniversitesi'nde öğrenim görünümü
sağlayan bursu bir kez kazanmış ve
elimde olmayan nedenlerden dolayı bunu
kayıpmış Bursa kazanmış olmaması sadece
ama sadece 268 ettim Çok fena tökezlemiş
ve ayağıma
da kocaya gelmedi ile düşüp adeta kafayı
yüzü yapmıştım ancak Sonraki sene girmem
gereken sınavdan Bu kez daha yüksek bir
puan aldım ve boşuna tekrar kazanıp
Hollanda'dan üniversiten kabul almıştım
ama iyi geçen mülakat sonunda oksfort
Üniversitesi'nde doktora öğrenimi
başlamaya karar verdim Yarın arkadaşlar
herkes düşer ama tekrar ayağa kalkmak
işte kolay değil Eğer tekrar ayağa kalk
arıyorsanız Siz dünyanın en güçlü
insanısınız ve az önce zorluklarla dolu
hikayesini kısaca anlattım bu evrenin
bir parçası olarak görevinizi layıkıyla
yerine getirmiş sizdedir üzüntüleriniz
in son kullanım tarihi Maximum 24 saat
olsun Nitekim sabah yine güneşte olacak
ölüm sessizliğinde hayatın çığlıklarına
milyarlarca yıl süren bu yolculuk
sonunda işler hepimiz buradayız bir
parçası olduğumuz Evren bizim
hayatımızda örnek almamız gereken yegane
kılavuzu evrenin bu kuş uçmaz kervan
geçmez
bu hayatın başlaması Tek kelimeyle bir
mucize ancak bir istisnasız ettiğimiz
kuruyup ölen bir çiçek gibi ki ölüp
toprak olacağız ve her canlı varoluşun
öncekilere boştur her bir gün kilo
olacaksak bunun bir amaç olsun öyle
güzel yanım ki ışığımız geleceği attınız
başka çiçeklerin başka umutlarını
dolması için kalın sağlayacak
teşekkürler